je suis votre commandant de bord ladies
and gentleman et ses yeux au capitaine
et speaking aller voir un film qui
s'appelle avions côte ou si je mens vie
dusty tu n'es pas taillé pour la course
tu est fait pour faire pousser le maïs
je m'appelle dusty jour de fred testot
et pas tout seul dans ta tête banon je
suis pas tout seul dans ma tête c'est ça
qui vient pred je trouve que c'est la
personne qui peut le mieux représenté la
personnalité de steve donc le choix il y
des ânes
ah ouais c'était vivant est
impressionnant
moi je joue le rôle de dusty testé qui
est un petit avion épandeur cet avion a
plein de rêves et veut gagner le grand
concours de tous les avions du tour du
monde va-t-il réussir
va-t-il accomplir son rêve et pourquoi
pas les petits sont dénigrés les petits
n'ont aucune chance
et bien je vous dis non je suis de ch'ti
et je vais me battre sans jamais être
méchant
on arrive le beaucoup l'a vendu on
arrive on va plaire aux vacances et pas
forcément avec l'autre la morale de ce
dessin demi est ce que je trouve
intéressant en termes de valeur c'est de
montrer que quelle que soit sa condition
si on y croit et qu'on a un objectif
quel qu'il soit il peut paraître
totalement démesurée inatteignable c'est
possible ou toi tu viens de bombay et
tué la championne du monde panasiatique
micheline qui sait la plupart des gens
m'appellent scellement icha ni de style
va tomber sous le charme de chagny qui
ne tomberait pas souche ambitieux ni
chez beaucoup de fans ici et ils
espèrent tous le voir gagner c'est
peut-être pour cette fois ich annie bel
avion très bel avion elle vient de
bombay est là elle a énormément de fans
de et en même temps je pense qu'elle va
apprendre beaucoup de dusty étaient déjà
allés au taj mahal
non non je ne crois pas
on y va ouais à l'école jusqu'à 3 1 2 3
les bizarres seydoublen et thales sont
pas des traîtres
il est un rayon de soleil après toute
une vie dans les ténèbres
j'étais doublement flatté qu'on me
propose rochelle excusez moi
savez vous combien pèse un chasse neige
non ok il ya évidemment le symbole
français qui est amusant et puis elle
est drôle moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
de sortir aussi un peu de ce que je fais
d'habitude et je suis la glace dure
froide et sans vie tu sais quoi
tennis toi tout seul et le souk route
patrouille de france
on a quelquefois rectifier un petit peu
les textes tant que ça colle un petit
peu plus à la réalité
non mais c'est quoi ce délire de
contribuer à petit peu plus à ce que
l'aéronautique soit soit vulgarisé et
diffuser et mais pour nous c'est très
important encore papa 32 l'autorisation
d'atterrissage piste 03 confirmé vitesse
d'un proche
ils pensent qu'a eu un gros travail
effectivement pour se rapprocher le plus
de la réalité
donc c'est très bluffant le résultat à
la fois sonore et visuel est très
impressionnant ah ben c'est très beau et
très bien fait oui j'avais adoré cars et
je trouve c'est dans la même lignée
c'est une super histoire d'un outsider
c'est comme blanche neige
non mais il ya des nains c'est une belle
histoire que celle de dusty moi je suis
heureuse de savoir qu'elle va toucher un
public je connais bien et qu'ils avaient
aussi envie de faire plaisir
les enfants voyager pendant une heure et
demie et les parents aussi et c'est ça
qui est génial